Abigale your parents and I feel that it
might be better if you started school
with your own class this way you can
start off the year just like everyone
else
hey what was that name everybody could
call her last year
my name is Jimmy would you guys ever
read The Crucible Arthur Miller Abigail
Williams this is the villain of the play
it's a great great great part it's a
difficult part anyone want to try to
tackle that I'm gonna have to go with
the namesake Abigail how'd it go
thanks for doing this it's not really
anyone else supposed to I don't have
anyone that I'm really close to at it
I'll do the scene with you
[Music]
what if I told you
you wanted someone quiet I just kept
running fast away from my coming back
you can forget today Joe you got that
line and you let me down he said why
didn't you pick me for that why did you
pick her you know she was in a psych
ward for like six months her
he doesn't know some pedophile you
really not see that Jesus jealous
[Music]